hier dimanche 26 avril c'était la
journée du souvenir des victimes de la
déportation une date pour se souvenir et
honoris et 700 mille femmes hommes et
enfants enfermés dans les camps de la
mort pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
cette année c'était d'ailleurs le 75e
anniversaire de la libération des camps
de concentration mais pas de cérémonie
hier pour autant en raison des mesures
sanitaires et du confinement
on parle de cette date anniversaire avec
viviane bouthillier bonsoir sa
présidente des amis de la fondation pour
la mémoire de la déportation des
yvelines et également avec nous et hervé
fleury bonsoir bonsoir vous vous êtes
donc fils et petit fils de déporté
vice-président également de
l'association des déportés internés et
familles des disparus des yvelines une
première question avoue hervé fleury
comment pouvait-on honorer ce jour
malgré l'absence de cérémonie comment
pouvait-on se se souvenir de ces femmes
hommes et enfants qui sont qui ont été
enfermés dans ces camps de concentration
je crois que le meilleur moyen c'était
de revivre dans nos familles la mémoire
de ceux qui ont vécu cette période
terrible cette déportation soit une
déportation raciale soit une déportation
en politique comme ce fut le cas dans ma
famille donc ressortir les photos
prendre un temps de silence
en regardant ces photos en écoutant le
chant des marais qui est l'hymne des
déportés avoir un temple d'intériorité
pour être en lien avec eux et se penser
à tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour que nous
soyons aujourd'hui libres dans notre
confinement et viviane boussier alors
vos associations respectives ont honte
appelé les maires des communes des
yvelines
malgré cette absence
deux cérémonies à à tous même ceux
mobilisés même de manière symbolique
pour honorer ce jour c'est ça exactement
il était convenu que dans la mesure où
on pouvait chaque président de
délégation donc dans chaque départements
envoyé une lettre au maire le disons
leur rappelant l'importance de ces
journées leur rappelant que c'était
comme le dit monsieur fleury il 75 2 75e
anniversaire donc ça avait besoin quand
même d'être un petit peu mis en valeur
et pour sensibiliser bain de faire selon
la façon qu'ils le voulaient a rappelle
rappelle alors alors administré un dépôt
de gerbe et discours à chaque heure
faisant ce qu'ils voulaient mais l'idée
était de me le dit monsieur fleuri de
montrer l'importance de cette journée à
la fois comme tous les ans depuis 1954
mais aussi pour l'anniversaire
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de l'eure des
yvelines qui vous ont fait un retour
positif qui vous ont assuré deux de
leurs engagements sur sur cette journée
beaucoup je ne ferai pas de statistiques
mais il ya eu des retours oui certains
disant tu ne le ferait avec le 8 mai de
façon à jumeler les deux peut-être pour
des questions toutes simples
d'administration et de vidéos ce qui
peut se comprendre aussi
mais il ya eu des retours y compris j'ai
eu des photos de mairie ayant des
projets soit le maire soit des adjoints
afin dé selon le cas une gerbe au pied
du monument n'a est peut-être un cas
particulier hervé fleury voûte y est élu
dans la ville de versailles qu'est ce
qui a été fait justement dans cette
ville de versailles pour cette journée
alors au monument aux morts de la ville
de versailles qui est chef lieu du
département il y a le recueil des
cendres de déportés de d'une dizaine de
camps et devant cette plaque mémoriale
il y a il a été déposée deux vasques de
fleurs par les services de
ville à la demande du maire qui lui-même
a fait un petit message vidéo et mallet
s'est aussi exprimée par un message
vidéo
l'appel recueillant pour ce 75e
anniversaire de la libération des corps
et ce 75e anniversaire viviane dossier
devait être aussi l'occasion de publier
le travail sur lequel vous avez donc
oeuvré pendant cinq ans et un travail
sur un mémorial des déportés des
yvelines qui recense actuellement 1014
non oui c'est ça en fait pour le 70e
anniversaire je fais pas l'erreur on
avait convenu de revoir le mémorial de
chaque département est en fait une
déclinaison départementale du mémorial
national de la fondation vraiment la
déportation et donc on a travaillé
pendant cinq ans et on a retrouvé des
noms des déportés sans distinction que
ce soit aussi bien des portes et qu'on
appelle résistants politique politique
n'y a aucune connotation politique ce
sont les résistants qui étaient opposés
ou au nazisme et ou bien de gigant soit
juif et on nous sommes partis environ à
deux chiffres six ans non il y a cinq
ans et nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 1020
parce que depuis tous les dix ans dans
la retrouver veut dire que y est c'est
un peu comme une épreuve de file quand
on commence à dérouler on retrouve
d'autres noms etc
les deux critères étant il faut bien que
on se bat qu'on sache et de critères si
je veux dire on le met dans le mémorial
les yvelines et temps comme dans tous
les départements
1 tous les départements de france le
fonds est en soi la naissance dans les
yvelines soit l'arrestation les yvelines
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya forcément des
déportés qui vivait à versailles mais
qu'ils sont à versailles dans les
yvelines
mais qui ne sont pas nés dans les
yvelines julien qui ont été arrêtés pour
un tas de raisons 1 en dehors donc
qu'ils ne sont pas
sur le mémorial mais comme chaque
département le fait ils seront dans un
autre mémorial l'idée étant d'un
mémorial national pour retrouver une
amérique où le mot de la fin et vous
hervé fleury vous qui êtes fils petit
fils de déporté pourquoi à l'heure où
les derniers témoins disparaissent aussi
peu à peu il n'y a pas forcément ces
derniers témoins de cette période il
faut continuer tout de même ce devoir de
mémoire continue de se souvenir pourquoi
c'est important
pourquoi cette importance parce que nos
parents et nos grands parents nous ont
montré leur amour de la france et se
sont engagés pour qu'un jour nous
retrouvions pour qu'un jouet retrouvions
pardon je bafouille et c'est l'émotion
la liberté et cette liberté et ils l'ont
payé très cher par la déportation en
s'engageant aux côtés les alliés pour
libérer la france
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose donc la première chose
l'amour du pays
et la deuxième chose c'est que nous
devons travailler toutes les
associations et au sens vraiment très
large du monde associatif pour défendre
la dignité de l'homme
parce que sans cesse la dignité de
l'homme est remise en cause
il n'y a qu'à voir ce qui se passe
partout dans le monde donc nous les
enfants nous sommes porteurs de cette
espèce de mission de travailler pour la
défense de la dignité de l'homme
merci pour ce message et merci d'avoir
été avec nous hervé fleury a dit jan bos
et merci à vous merci et à bientôt